everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
you're watching the askgaryvee show
episode 13 fun fact about the number 13
is my sister was born on Friday the 13th
Luke asks what's the fastest way someone
can piss you off
ruk you know it's interesting I'm not
the kind of character that gets pissed
off so quickly I'm pretty much a love
and Zen kind of guide for all my
intensity I think that throws people off
a little bit in reality obviously if you
punched me directly in the face or hurt
somebody I care about
right here that would be bad but overall
the actual answer to your question is
hypocrisy and cynicism those are the two
things that I can't consume the amount
of cynics out there it's really one of
the funnier kind of cards that people
play on social media specifically I see
played less in real life really bothers
me and boy if you're complaining about
something you actually do and I have
some friends and family members to play
that that just drives me up the wall
Vineyard Paul asks how do y-you snapchat
for a winery then you Paul how to use
this question because the image is
incredible loved it great way to ask
your question
if you want to get your question on
askgaryvee show you need to be a little
bit creative like vineyard Paul alright
so snapchat here some people have to
understand
I predict I'm going to hardcore here I
predict in 2016 that snapchat will have
a number one two or three spot in the
most important apps in the world from
the 13 to 40 let me say it again
forty-year-old sector maybe even 45 of
50 I'm that the 25 to 50 year old sector
on snapchat in 2016 is gonna blow away
the far majority of people who are
watching this episode and so let me give
you a fun fact on how to get good at it
or start playing with it the one big
creative play that I see on snapchat
that makes it so different is the notion
of
taking a picture and then drawing on top
of it someone do you follow me I've seen
things that weird spider the raindrops
I'll start to play with it a little bit
I'm a big fan of that it opens up
enormous creativity enormous goal do you
run some of my funny snaps I don't know
where you're putting them d-roc but and
so I'll give you those images yeah so if
your winery take pictures in the wine
room in the vineyard of the bottle and
then draw creative things around it I do
think that people will enjoy that it'll
be a little haha you can do some little
contests by running in I think drawing
on top of the images because the images
on Instagram and Facebook and Twitter
are they all look the same this drawing
thing is a real creative variable it is
a difference maker the attentions on
snapchat
I am bullish on that dosed hi Gary my
name is we're a four-person team and we
are seeing a rapid growth in our
customer base currently we have a very
intimate customer experience but I'm
kind of worried that as we grow we may
have more and more trouble with
maintaining that is there any advice you
could give me thank keek there's some
serious advice that I can give you which
is if you grow thank god you will make
money or you will raise money those are
two things that happen when you grow and
you will take some of that money and you
will apply it to hiring more human
beings to continue to scale your
four-person team to a 23 person team
that can then you obviously in that
scenario around six times more engaging
and intimacy this is the insanity that
pisses me off more than anything which
is that people think that engagement
doesn't scale it doesn't scale when you
roll like me and you answer everything
yourself but it does scale when you're a
logo of water a league a thing it scales
as a matter of fact I've been
contemplating an askgaryvee show Twitter
account that allows me to scale right I
can have four human beings behind the
show engaging you know That's not me
because it's a show me is me and so you
can scale all day long are you and your
four-person team willing to make the
commitment to allocate dollars into
humans one that most CFOs and other
financial people do not believe in I
believe in it do you mark and Patty ask
what's better for content blogging or
blogging mark and Paddy this is a great
question and this is something that I
you know I'm really glad you asked this
question because I've been drilling
drilling i've been thrilling to drill
i've been hoping to drill this home for
quite a while and i used to address this
back in two thousand seven eight nine
definitely oh nine and ten during the
crush it tour and the crush of days i
answered this a lot haven't talked about
as much last four years that's why we do
the askgaryvee show it allows me to rant
about things i've forgotten about the
answer is I don't know the answer is
very simple what are you good at you can
crush it doing video blogging and you
can crush it doing blogging I mean it
just comes down to what are you good at
are you better at video since I started
this show I've already seen eleven to
twelve ask shows pop up of people that
follow me of people that pay attention
to what I'm doing and you know very
honestly one or two or decent and the
other nine are straight crap with all
due respect to my fans I don't want to
diss that's not a good thing to do of
the eleven people that have done it or
now sitting there saying does he think
I'm crap why do you think I said two
more okay I don't want anybody feel bad
but you know some people are made out to
I'm not made out to write like myself I
need editing I need it I need help
grammar I can't spell I can't do it I
can't do it guys I can't spell a boy can
I make a video
drew asks do you have any tips on
presenting your consultant services to a
potential client drew isn't this a funny
little yin and yang one-two with the
last question I don't know I mean the
answer is are you good at making a
PowerPoint can you make a video that's
like a little bit of a better or can you
sell like me which is forget everything
else and just walk in and close the deal
there are the last two questions are
questions that happen all the time and
here's what I will tell you I appreciate
the kind words that tweets the
admiration that I see in the comments
I've been following very carefully it's
been so fun and the feedbacks incredible
I really appreciate it but let me tell
you one thing what works for me does not
necessarily work for you so many of you
do so many things better than I do that
it makes me want to vomit on this
football like you know and what you need
to do is take a step back ask your
friends if you're not self aware or EQ
oriented but you need to figure out what
you're good at the answer to your
question the answer to the last question
and the answer to a lot of things I'm
seeing using the hashtag askgaryvee are
very personal questions that I would
never know unless I've known you I know
Zak right I know Steve right I know is
it run your neck I don't care I'm taking
it yeah that's right I don't know don't
worry sorry oh shoot this is what
happened I got I know d-roc right
I know these characters a little bit
like I know I'm getting to know the more
I have a sense of their strengths and
weaknesses and I would like to think
that if you ever talk to them on the
corner screen or a conference or you
talk to him on Twitter I spent a lot of
time trying to figure out how to put
them in the best position to succeed
based on what I think they're good at
and I could do that for you if I had a
lot of time but I don't and the reality
is very simple you need to figure that
out the answer to that question the one
before and the one that so many of you
have is predicated on your natural
god-given ability or the things that
you've worked very hard at to amass that
scale period Michael asks what criteria
do you use to determine if what you're
creating is valuable Michael for me this
is a really interesting question and
depends are you talking about
is the content that you're putting out
valuable because I talk a lot about that
and you know that is you know what I use
on that criteria is actually engagement
numbers I mean just raw numbers how many
people are sharing how many people are
leaving comments you know how many
people are watching the video like
that's a very important very basic
engagement number that helps you know
that's but that's one baseline number
the way I really do it like overall is
how many people are buying right how
many books that I sell because I
provided so many global jabs that you on
the other side this camera felt like you
needed to buy it how many great pieces
of content or best buying ability or
pricing that I put out for the wine that
I sold during Wine Library that made
people buy thousand
cases how good have I built this company
that the fortune 500 companies and the
companies that can afford hiring us and
how often are they hiring us when we're
pitching at the end of the word today
the way I judge it is by the results
that I'm looking for whether it's to
sell some consulting whether it's to
sell some books I know it's a football
whether it's to get people to watch and
share you know how happy would make me
to see every single person watch this
video share this video you know I mean
that's an important thing to me anyway I
didn't do the subscribe button last
episode so I just want to do one big one
thanks to your rocket question of the
day I've decided that I want to show up
right now I'm getting very you to be but
I decided that I want to show up on some
YouTube celebrities shows look at a
travel looking at Apes stuff look at a
hack any suggestions whose show should I
randomly show up on you keep asking
questions and I'll keep trying to answer
them question of the day
oh you got you got something you do it
one more well then let's go to it
you
[Music]